Steve Mariucci my compadre from NFL
gameday morning has called that the
pride of the Northern Michigan
University here on the Rich Eisen show
once again how are you mooch
good morning rich you had you had Matt
Ryan on earlier the natural has already
called it yes well I gotta be honest
with you I'm kind of proud I didn't even
bring it up did he know it was a minute
vanished
[Music]
well if that was gonna be the Maddy ice
if that was gonna be the result then I
would have definitely brought it up but
when I was watching that I'm sure
everybody else - here we go again I felt
that rich I was I was saying it out loud
here we go again oh my god 24 points up
and here comes Aaron Rodgers well he
swear he said I mean Brockman you can
back it up he said we don't even think
about it anymore
what do you think everybody in the
stands was thinking about I can't wait
to see that Stadium man did that look
awesome well it did and guess what the
the the Thursday night were there with
the chick-fil-a will be open Steve oh
yeah we're there I can't wait yeah but
they're better on defense they are
aren't they they'd look out you know
those four rookies that they played last
year alter kind of grow up new these
there's no sophomore slump and then you
add on Terry Poe did you see that guy I
did see that guy no he he he was a good
addition and Desmond true Fonts back and
and yeah he was you know he plays nice
tight man coverage and got the big pick
at the end there and and made it rough
on there I gotta tell you Steve two
weeks in and I know we're it's just one
eighth of the season with all due
respect to Carolina being the other to a
no team in the NFC the Falcons have got
to be the team to beat in this
conference I think so because what you
just mentioned their defense is better
and that's true okay definitely better
on defense and that was their their
Achilles heel last year right and their
offense didn't come out of the gate fast
against the Bears it was a little sloppy
remember we did a little Warner's corner
and and Curt just ripped on them a
little bit look he doesn't know what it
just takes time it with a new play
caller a new coordinator and Steve
Sarkisian and it looks like hey they
start they're starting to to get it and
Julio Jones is involved and they got two
great running backs and in Mattie Isis
Maddy ice and he's going to be an MVP
candidate
and in maybe so cuz Delos showed the
vulnerability and and obviously the
packers did in Seattle who certainly did
so maybe right now the team to be in the
NFC is is the offense against so let's
sit those other two right now I open the
show by saying that the Giants don't
just own the blueprint anymore on how to
beat the Cowboys and and Green Bay's
blueprint last year was let's just stick
ahead red-hot quarterback in Dallas and
and hit him in the mouth
I think Denver showed a blueprint on
right so you tell tell me well I mean
how did how did Dallas look as poor
poorly as they did yesterday so Denver
course is a good football team right I
mean that we know we've known they're
good on defense but with the way they're
built on defense rich they've got three
cover guys that are probably better than
anybody else's three cover guys in the
league with a keep to leave and Chris
Harrison Bradley Roby okay and what they
did is they played man-to-man nice tight
man-to-man coverage they're not if they
can run with anybody does does I want to
say hi what 16 targets or something like
that and and you know he had a few
catches but you know then and then they
stayed base with their front seven
against the run and they loaded up the
box with their base front and played
three corners and one safety in the game
quite a bit at a time and so it was
that's a real interest not every team
can do this so who are the other teams
that can do that in the innocent least
gosh nobody has three great corners like
that but if you don't if you have two
good corners you still can load the box
up and play man-to-man right you can
play your nickel defense but then put
your safeties and you know closer to the
box Ezekiel Elliott got really
frustrated right there was nowhere to go
and so they stopped the run with numbers
and they stopped and slow down the past
with tight man-to-man coverage it was it
was unbelievable and then of course your
quarterbacks got a play well Trevor
Simeon did you know he won that job and
we made an issue out of it competition
with Paxton Lynch he won that job hands
down no that's no doubt about it Steve
well I mean in LT LaDainian on on game
day prom last night with Deon said
Eliott quit on the Cowboys flat-out quit
on the Cowboys and then there was that
one instance where there was an
interception where he stood with his
hands on his hips and watched other
teammates try to track the the play down
and folks think that that Jason Garrett
should discipline Elliott for that how
would you handle the situation Steve
yeah that's an interesting scenario too
because I think it shows his immaturity
where you know he's so he's so used to
having an honored yards rushing in a
game or whatever 80 yards +4 15 out of
17 games is unheard of and then all of a
sudden it doesn't go your way and you
pout or you show disapproval or whatever
that is I think it's a maturity thing
and and I think he's got to learn to
that it's not gonna always go his way
well how would you handle it as a coach
I mean what would you do yeah I'd
probably sit him down I I'd have to see
it I you know I I heard about it I
haven't seen it in all that but or saw
his comments or his demeanor in the
locker room sometimes guys get verbal
and sometimes they get animated and
sometimes he just get quiet I probably
sit him down and say listen yeah it's
not gonna always be easy you're gonna
have tough games you just got to kind of
fight through it and be a good teammate
and go through these the ups and downs
if you want to have active a career
you're gonna get a little bit everything
so just deal with it and and he will he
will but it was this was an eye opener
for the kid it was like oh my god it's
not as easy as maybe I thought it was
gonna be all the time Steve Mariucci my
compadre from NFL gameday morning and he
will be with me as it's a home game for
him literally when we're in San
Francisco San Jose area for the week 3
kickoff between the Rams and 49ers on
Thursday night what gives huh rich I'm
still trying to plan if we're gonna come
over to my house and you know go down
the wine cellar and have some pasta and
some vino before the game I was on
Wednesday night so it would figure out
our schedules well Brockman and del 2 fo
are signaling because they're coming
with us to come in we'll figure it out
mooch ok but yeah save two seats and
then a couple of portions you know for
one of the two so what gives with the
Seattle offense Steve what's going on
there
oh yeah yeah I know it huh I mean they
were better than that in the preseason
and then you'll watch them against the
Niners and it's like where did they go
now train
sometimes the rain bases look difficult
but you know they just they just aren't
hitting on like they want to and and you
you had 312 yards off and so they're
balanced with some passing and some
rushing but they don't throw the ball in
turn the ball over but they've only
scored one touchdown now in two games
and so I don't know I thought I thought
Seattle would be another team in the NFC
that we would mention as a contender is
their scheme too simple you know Tom
Campbell was their offensive line coach
I know Tommy was one of my assistant
coaches at Cal yeah really good coach
been head coach to the Raider anyway
he's on my he's on my three rich and so
they think that he can just pull off
miracles all the time you know and and
then George you know fan the left tackle
was hurting a preseason blew his knee
out and now they had a replacement over
there and they've been playing musical
chair with some young guys on the
offensive line three years and they
expect him just to be good and without
drafting high and then you know like the
Dallas Cowboys did and in you know he's
dealing with guys that are probably
gonna be just okay just just okay but I
mean running for his life they don't run
the ball like they wanted to they they
brought in Eddie Lacy to replace beast
mode that didn't happen they benched him
right they didn't even play on this game
but what about this Steve I mean with
Darrell Bevell
they're everybody's poached Pete
Carroll's defensive coaches they try to
get Tom cable and and and he stuck
around there cuz I guess the opportunity
wasn't there nobody's knocking on the
door for Darrell Bevell
and and and shouldn't that scream
something I mean the number of Seattle
fans that would love to see a change at
this pot in the same way that Marvin
Lewis just made one after two weeks I
mean this has been going on for years I
mean what's the answer here I think I
think you got a you got a look at the
full general philosophy of a head coach
he builds his team around defense that
they spend money on defense and they
like a close it's kind of like the
Baltimore Ravens when they were playing
good football and good defense you keep
the score down and your offensive scheme
and philosophy is to
run the ball be balanced don't screw it
up don't turn it over you're not you're
not shotgun throwing it 50 times that's
just not how they want to play offensive
football and so they they win games low
scoring and and with just efficient
football on offense and and that's
that's what they've been doing so
Darrell Bevell is not going to be
considered a guru by playing offense
that way and Russell Wilson's the
exactly kind of guy to do that he can
throw it or run it or scramble around
like crazy if need be so that's just how
it is I don't count them out
I think Seattle be better as they go
they just yeah I'm with you I'd like
them to be more efficient and explosive
on offense too before I let you go who's
the best team in the AFC through two
weeks do you think was the best team in
the AFC through two weeks well the best
team yesterday were the Patriots and
they didn't they sure didn't look at the
first game but there they are again and
and I was just so impressed with with
Tom Brady's 447 and how they play and
they they get all these new guys you
know Gil's Lee has 18 carries and you
got Birkhead I mean these guys are from
other teams that were just okay and all
of a sudden you know bill check make
some stars and and so we've got to
really watch it though with the Patriots
because they got a bet they don't he's
suited up three wide receivers and two
of them got hurt in this game you know
Hogan came limping off and so did
Phillip Dorsett and Gronk did do so it's
going to be interesting with their with
her injury report but they look really
good all right mucho C in San Francisco
a couple days or San Jose
I guess he at the house on Wednesday
night met you got a mooch Delta okay you
got bye take care that says Steve
Mariucci the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to